the facade of notre dame remains but the
heart of the 800 year old cathedral has
been turned to ash is there any more
fitting metaphor for the state of
Western civilization we will analyze the
difference between appearance and
reality from Paris all the way to the
2020 presidential primaries I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
a brutal news cycle yesterday watching
the Cathedral of Notre Dom burning the
spire falling there there are some
silver linings here some of it has been
saved but the broader take away is not
even just about this priceless Cathedral
this defining aspect of the West it's a
broader cultural problem we'll get to it
in a second but first this is an awkward
thing to talk about but sex especially
within marriage is one of the crucial
aspects of a healthy life frankly one of
the main reasons to get out of bed in
the morning now sometimes things don't
work out like they're supposed to that's
nothing to be ashamed about that's where
our friends at Roman come in studies
show 70 percent of guys who experience a
wreck tile dysfunction do not get
treated for it thankfully Roman created
an easy way to get checked out by a
doctor and get treated for IDI online
Roman is one stop shop where you can
chat with a licensed u.s. physician who
can treat IDI and if safe and
appropriate ship medication right to
your door with Roman there are no
waiting rooms
no awkward face-to-face conversations
and know uncomfortable trips to the
pharmacy nobody wants to be asking for
that sort of thing at the pharmacy it
can be very awkward and uncomfortable
you can handle everything discretely
online all you have to do is visit get
Roman comm slash Noel's
ko wles complete an online visit chat
with a doctor and if the doctor decides
it would be safe and appropriate they
will ship genuine medication right to
your door in discreet unmarked packaging
I repeat discreet and unmarked packaging
so don't worry about it go online get
checked by the doctor erectile
dysfunction is a problem that guys don't
tackle with Roman it's really simple so
take care of it for a free online visit
go to get Roman comm slash Noel's kendo
wles
that is get Roman comm slash Noel's for
a free online visit get Roman comm slash
Noel's so back to the West burning the
Cathedral at Notre Dom caught fire
yesterday we don't know what caused it
we don't know what is going to happen
now how they're going to rebuild what
that could even mean about rebuilding
Elon omar us freshman congresswoman
tweeted out something that so typifies
our culture I'm actually not going after
her because she's defending terrorists
this time I'm not going after her
because she's downplaying terrorist
attacks I'm not going after for the
reasons we've been going after her for
the past couple of weeks I'm going after
her because unfortunately her response
to the burning of nutri dom exemplifies
our culture it shows you just what's
wrong and with a culture that would let
notre dam burn she said quote art and
architecture have a unique ability to
help us connect across our differences
and bring people together in important
ways thinking of the people of paris and
praying for every first responder trying
to save this wonder okay so she's saying
we're thinking of these people in paris
do you notice what word was missing
cathedral art and architecture have a
unique ability to help us connect across
our differences sure I get is she
referring to that painting on the wall
behind me that abstract modern
catastrophe no she's talking about a
Cathedral but she won't say the word
Cathedral it's just art and architecture
thinking of the people of Paris art and
architecture that's all it is no it's
more than that it has meaning and if you
don't think it has meaning
that's the rot in the culture the rot in
now the ruins of notre 'adam is a symbol
of the rot in this Western culture now
how did it start we don't know how it
started officials are apparently ruling
out terrorism and arson if this was
suggested it might be an act of
terrorism or arson and yet the
mainstream media are refusing to even
entertain that possibility
yesterday Shepard Smith on Fox News shut
a guy down within seconds of even
raising the possibility
so of course you will hear the story
abut the politically correct the
political correctness which will tell
you that it's probably an accident sir
sir sir we're not going to speculate
here
of the cause of something which we don't
know if you have observation if you have
observations or you know something we
would love to hear it I'm just telling
you something what will you need to be
already no sir we're not doing that here
not now okay not on my watch
no no no no lalalalala
we can't possibly ask why this happened
lalalalala now why does he bring up the
possibility that this was arson or
terror because there's been a spate of
desecrations at churches and cathedrals
all throughout France just in the last
weeks there have been statues smashed
Tabernacles knocked down the tabernacle
for those who don't know is the box that
houses the Blessed Sacrament the
Eucharist the communion all of these
things that the Eucharist has been
desecrated crosses have been torn down
just last Sunday at the Church of San
Soo peace where we set on fire that that
is not as old as notre-dame obviously
but it's a very old church it dates back
to the 17th century last month at the
church of st. Nicholas in we friends the
statue of the Virgin Mary was smashed in
February the altar cloth was burned and
crosses and statues of saints were
smashed at Santa LAN Cathedral in France
at the at the Church of notre-dame des
enfant
that was they were that was looted a
cross at that church was smeared with
human excrement obviously something is
going on at these churches something is
motivating these attacks something is
causing people to set churches on fire
and desecrate sacraments and statues and
altars but no no we can't just no no
lalalalala we can't possibly discuss
that also why would someone raise the
possibility that this was arson or
terror because of the timing the
Cathedral of notre-dame burned down on
the first day of Holy Week Holy Week is
what begins the time as you lead into
Good Friday and to Easter Sunday and on
that Monday the Cathedral of Notre Dom
burns down so I don't I don't think it's
so awful that people are raising
questions but as that gentleman said
before
Shepard Smith cut him off it's not
politically correct to raise that
question now the authorities are saying
it doesn't seem as though his arson
doesn't seem as though it was terror
okay I sure would like to know what did
cause it now on the bright side there is
a silver lining here a lot of relics a
lot of artwork was saved from within the
Cathedral I mean there were priceless
artifacts in Notre Dom there's a relic
the the crown of thorns that was placed
on Christ's head was in no trade on and
father jean-marc Fournier who's the
chaplain of the Paris Fire Brigade he
ran into the burning Cathedral to save
that relic to save the crown of thorns
and to save the Blessed Sacrament so to
save the Eucharist the body of Christ he
runs in to save it there there is
another relic and nail from the true
cross the cross on which Christ was
crucified that was saved unfortunately
part of the crown of thorns a piece of
it was stored in the spire that is
believed to have been destroyed when
that spire burned down
and although the facade remains
apparently structurally intact the roof
completely burned down the frame of that
roof which dates back to the 12th
century 800 year old roof over 800 years
old destroyed this oak that dates back
upwards of a thousand years destroyed
and what does macron say the leader of
France he says they will rebuild I hope
so
that would be nice other conservatives
other Christians other people in France
have called for it to be rebuilt that
would be nice it would be wonderful to
be able to rebuild no tree Dom but you
can you can do something you can try to
restore parts of it you can try to
somehow move forward but but you can't
rebuild it exactly
first of all any attempt to rebuild it
will take decades the cathedral took
over a century to build and it won't be
the same
it just won't be the same this is the
sad thing we don't want to acknowledge
this in our culture because we think we
can replace everything you break your
computer all you can replace that you
drop your iPhone you get a new iPhone oh
we can replace this we can well rebuild
the house we'll rebuild this you can't
rebuild no trade on
why can't you rebuild no trade on one we
don't really even know how that roof was
built there is so much technical
knowledge that has been lost over the
centuries this is hard for us to imagine
because we think we're modern and we
know everything and everyone before us
was an idiot we don't know how to build
that roof we don't know exactly what
they did
technical knowledge can be lost but
moreover it took so long to build that
it took so much commitment it took such
a strength of the Catholic Church it
took such a unity between the church and
the state to build no trade on those
don't exist anymore
Western Christendom is such a shadow of
its former self you can't rebuild no
trade on this burning is in many ways a
symbol of the decay of the faith
throughout Europe Hilaire Belloc the
writer once said a famous line got him
in trouble his controversial he said the
faith is Europe and Europe is the faith
he's referring to the Catholic faith
Western Christendom that is what defines
Europe when that cracks what is Europe
what is left then note Radames not a
Cathedral it's a museum to listen to
people talk about notre-dame yesterday
to listen to pundits talk about it it
was as though they were talking about a
museum it was as though they were
talking like Ilan Omar art and
architecture oh no it's it's such a loss
of art and architecture it is but the
art and architecture means something
it's not just a museum it's a Cathedral
it is animated by a living faith and if
that faith disappears from Europe then
you just have ruins you have ruins
before it burned to the ground
how can you rebuild that and if it isn't
real by the way why would you rebuild it
we'll get to that much harder question
in a second and we'll get to facades in
reality throughout the presidential
primary but first let's thank our
friends over at purple mattress you know
how much I love purple mattress you know
how upset I am because I'm on the road
right now and I don't get to sleep in my
purple mattress I have to sleep on that
bed and that bed is terrible in my hotel
room I love purple so much I've had back
problems my whole life
that purple mattress I tried it out I
was a little skeptical because it's firm
and soft at the same time how is that
possible I don't know it sleeps cool
it's this new technology which is
developed by a rocket scientist it's not
an innerspring it's not quite a memory
foam it's something new anyway I was
very skeptical I tried it out within 12
hours I said okay get rid of my old bed
this is what I want I'm gonna recommend
this to all of my friends it's fabulous
you will love purple you get a hundred
out risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your mattress
for a full refund backed by a 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns free
in-home setup and old mattress removal
you are going to love purple right now
my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide just
text knowles kano wles
to eight four eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is to text
knowles to eight four eight eight eight
k nowl es to eight four eight eight
eight message and data rates may apply
so to hear people talk about it from
Milano more to other commentators it is
as though no true DOM is more amusing
than a cathedral oh the Catholic faith
has been dying in France and Europe for
so long that the cathedral itself is a
relic of a bygone age that is no longer
animated by a true faith all those
actually all of those relics inside the
Cathedral the crown of thorns the nail
from the true cross so many others those
are kind of fun little historical
oddities obviously it's not the crown of
thorns obviously is not a nail from the
true cross obviously it was just
gullible foolish people who thought it
was that
but nevertheless they're historical
curiosities they're part of our history
and therefore it's a shame we lose them
we should preserve them because of their
history not because of their intrinsic
value not because of their faith not
because of the faith of Europe if no
trade ahhm isn't real if it isn't about
a true faith if it isn't about our lady
notre dom means our lady if it isn't
about the faith that defined and created
europe why would we rebuild it it won't
be the original thing if you want the
historical value that's gone that's
burned down if it's because you want to
look at the facades of notre 'adam okay
you already have the facades you can go
look at them if it isn't real its what
are you doing are you building
Disneyland well we don't believe in this
you know we don't believe in this
anymore but we'll rebuild it because
it's a part of France is that it it's
just part of its part of our national
history but that the history part is
gone if it's not real there's no reason
to rebuild and there's no motivation to
rebuild you're creating a husk you're
creating a grotesquerie you're creating
a zombie now if the faith is not dead
and it's never dead
it ebbs and it flows and there are
periods of faithlessness but it's never
dead if you build it because you believe
that it's real because it's all real
that would be one of the greatest
opportunities for the West certainly in
my lifetime and in recent history to say
we will not allow this to happen we will
not allow not just a building to burn
down but the animating force of our
civilization we will not allow that to
burn down we will rebuild because Holy
Week isn't just about the crucifixion
and death Holy Week ends happily and
joyfully Holy Week is about the
resurrection
if we can say that then the future of
Europe is bright the future of our
civilization is bright the future of us
individually is bright can we do that
I'm not so sure this reminds me of
another trend I just saw this the other
day in the San Francisco game it was a
headline the funeral as we know it is
becoming a relic just in time for a
death boom
the funeral is becoming a relic what is
replacing it something called
celebration of life ceremonies here's
how the article begins
Dana West knows how to throw a fabulous
memorial shindig she hired la
celebration of life planner
Alison Bossert yes those now exist to
create what West's dubbed memorial
Palooza for her father Howard in 2016 a
few months after his death and Howard's
remembrance there was a crowd of more
than 300 people at Sony Pictures studios
a hotdog cart from the famed la stand
Pink's gift bags the hit being a
baseball cap inscribed with life's not
fair get over it a favorite Howard ISM a
constellation of speakers with Jerry
Seinfeld as the closer howard was his
personal manager and babka a tribute to
a favorite Seinfeld episode my dad never
followed the rules says West 56 a Bay
Area clinical psychologist so why would
his memorial service this is the
ridiculous consequence of materialism
this is the ridiculous
consequence of atheism the frivolous
consequence and it's so ironic is there
anything more depressing than a
celebration of life ceremony what are
you celebrating this reminds me of
people who if they're gonna go on
vacation or if they're gonna go on a
holiday or something they insist on
being really really happy they see if
we're gonna be happy nothing's going to
stop us from being happy yeah and
they're grinning their teeth and you
just think the lady doth protest too
much methinks
isn't that so she I don't know I don't
do you don't seem that happy the idea
here is no one here gets out alive life
is a tale told by an idiot full of sound
and fury signifying
thing we just turn and take a dirt nap
go right down become worm food and so
rather than focus on that sadness that
grief that we cannot face we're no
longer socially mature enough to face
that we're gonna pretend to have a happy
time we're in have hot dogs and Jerry
Seinfeld we're gonna have gift bags with
sardonic expressions on them life's not
fair get over it we're going to call it
a memorial Palooza instead of a funeral
now what is a funeral funeral typically
a little more sober a little more somber
a little more serious there's more
gravity to it why because a life has
ended and that's a sad thing
Christ himself when he goes to visit
Lazarus who he is about to resurrect
from the dead who he is about to bring
back to life his dead friend when he
goes and sees that his friend is dead he
weeps even Christ even the creator of
the universe weeps death is a is a sad
thing to pretend that it's not is absurd
it's a fantasy
you're trying to convince yourself of
something that isn't true
because you can't face a harsh reality
this is what we do in our culture all
the time now
inconvenient realities we brush away we
say they aren't true I'm a man who wants
to be a woman well okay I'm not really a
man I'm not I'm just that it isn't true
I am someone who's pregnant but I don't
want to have a baby okay I'm not really
pregnant I'm good that's not really a
person I'm now I'm gonna get rid of that
that's what we do now we we want to
avoid inconvenient realities because we
don't have the cultural and ultimately
religious apparatus to deal with them a
funeral is all is a celebration of life
ceremony in the truest sense because of
the hope of the resurrection
funerals are filled with grief we are
sad to lose our friends death is awful
we are so sad and yet there is hope hope
of the resurrection hope of heaven hope
of the life of the world to come and
that gives you something to celebrate
what on earth do you celebrate in a
celebration of life the meaninglessness
of our existence the utter tragedy that
we are born and we have passions and we
had accomplished things and we have
loves and Joy's and really they all turn
out for naught it was all just an
illusion whoops and we're gonna meet the
same fate ha ha isn't that awful I love
another hot dog it's not a celebration
it's a false celebration you're
pretending it's a celebration it's
actually despair but we we don't have
that apparatus anymore we don't have
that moral cultural religious
sophistication to say yes there is grief
and that grief is real and it is
covering a profound joy now we just have
a frivolous fake happiness ha ha ha and
by the way if the grief is a little too
much you'll just take a happy pill
you'll just take some antidepressant
drug as do so many Americans
prescriptions of those drugs
skyrocketing over prescription
skyrocketing and ok we'll be happy we'll
be happy happy ha ha will rebuild no
trade on ok I I hope we can but we're
not going to be able to rebuild it if we
don't understand what animates life you
are not going to be able to celebrate
life if you don't understand what life
is what life is geared toward what life
means what death means what resurrection
means profound mysteries to contemplate
especially during Holy Week
especially when a world historic event
has just happened the burning down of
the Cathedral of Notre Dom will we look
those realities directly in the face
will we confront them directly or will
we look away and pretend say no well
well we'll build another Museum no we'll
celebrate life pass me another hot dog
what will we do we think that we are
avoiding something difficult we think
that we're we think that we're setting
ourselves up for happiness when we
ignore these profound questions in these
profound mysteries we're not when you
look at death when you look at what
built the Cathedral not just the hands
not just the wood not just the stones
and the glass but what build it what
built it spiritually it reminds me of
that CS Lewis quote if you look for
truth you might find comfort in the end
but if you look for comfort you'll find
neither truth nor comfort only soft soap
and wishful thinking to begin and in the
end despair
will we be a culture of ultimate despair
or will we have hope look to the ashes
of Notre Dom see if you can see
resurrection we have got to say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube we've got a lot
more to get to particularly on how the
facade relates to reality in these
twenty twenty presidential primaries and
the new primary opponent against Donald
Trump oh I'm sure he's shaking but first
you gotta go to daily we're calm it is
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get them out wall show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag you get to
ask questions backstage you get all of
those things you get the leftist here's
tumblr that's the most important thing I
wish I had mine on the road depending on
how this talk tonight goes at Texas A&M
we'll have to see if I will survive the
drowning without my leftist ears tumblr
go to daily write calm we'll be right
back with a lot more
by the way if you are going to be in
Texas tonight come on out and hang out
with us if you're in College Station
tonight thirsty for some sweet sweet
leftist tears come to Texas A&M
University at 7:00 p.m. Central Time I
will be joined by none other than the
supreme master of the galactic
multiverse Andrew Clavin to enlighten
all of those comrades and snowflakes out
here it's the latest stop on my F campus
tour I very much hope to see you there
the questions of facade and reality are
not just about the faith of Europe and
they're not just about life and death
they do apply even to politics in 2020
because right now President Trump has
instituted a brilliant idea to other who
knows if it will actually become policy
but it's a great idea to get Democrats
on the defensive on a major campaign
issue president Trump has announced
plans to ship illegal aliens who enter
this country to sanctuary cities it's so
simple why didn't we think of it before
Democrats should be thrilled with this
plan right they love illegal aliens they
love sanctuary cities they say come
please give us your poor your huddled
masses come here to our cities we want
you right not so much here's cory booker
of speaking out of both sides of his
mouth do you think this is an empty
threat by the president though to talk
about busing people from the border into
these sanctuary cities he likes to
create frictions sometimes to jumpstart
he says a congress that's not acting you
say friction I say he's trying to pit
americans against each other and make us
less safe because what you're seeing now
so you take the threat seriously III
take this he is injecting fear into our
country and so if he was looking to
solve a problem he wouldn't be doing
things to divide this country against
itself beware of any anybody that's
trying to tell you to be afraid in the
strongest country in the world as
opposed to showing our strength and our
courage by pulling people together to
find common sense solutions to solve
this problem so first of all cory booker
is telling us never trust anyone who
tells you to be afraid
meanwhile he's telling us that Donald
Trump is making us all unsafe and he's
destroying the country and is dividing
the country hold on a second here that
by the transitive property I think that
means I can't trust Cory Booker right
he also though says that bringing all of
these illegal aliens to sanctuary cities
will make us less safe why would it make
us less safe
I thought illegal aliens never commit
any crimes no illegal aliens they're the
most law-abiding citizens in the entire
world
because they're not citizens they're
future citizens if cory booker gets his
way how could it make us less safe if
you're just shipping in all these super
safe people and if you are a city that's
offering sanctuary shouldn't you welcome
them know what the left ones is the
appearance but not the reality they want
the appearance of opening their arms to
illegal aliens but they don't want the
reality of illegal aliens no no no that
would be inconvenient and that would
probably hurt them with their voters as
well Nancy Pelosi saying exactly the
same thing
into democratic districts including
yours
I don't know anything about it but again
it's not just another notion that is
unworthy of the presidency of the United
States and disrespect will the
challenges that we face as a country as
a people to address who we are a nation
of immigrants right Nancy we're a nation
of immigrants so cities that are
offering sanctuary to all of those
illegal aliens that you're encouraging
to come into the country that seems like
a wonderful idea doesn't know what she
says is that it's a notion unworthy of
the President of the United States why
on earth is it unworthy I mean obviously
most of what she's saying is just total
gobbledygook singing and blah blah blah
and this is who we are blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah talking out of both
sides of her mouth but she wants the
appearance of encouraging all these
illegal aliens to come here she doesn't
want to deal with them and then the best
of all forget Booker forget Pelosi I
will never forget where I wasn't what I
was doing the moment that cher became a
Republican she tweeted this couple days
ago with random capitalization and
strange spelling and just like all of
the other cher tweets quote I understand
helping struggling immigrants but my
City Los Angeles isn't taking care of
its own what about the 50,000 plus
American citizens who live on the
streets what about the people who live
below the poverty line and are hungry if
my state can't take care of its own many
our vets
how can it take care of more did
President Trump write that tweet for her
great point cher you're absolutely right
so then why does your side of the aisle
encourage people to pour across the
country illegally this idea of President
Trump I don't know if he's actually
gonna do it I hope he does so far we're
seeing policy by tweet so you never know
if that's actually gonna be implemented
this is a brilliant idea and it's so
simple this is actually the road to
victory in 2020 at every turn you have
to make the left deal not just in the
appearance of the thing but with the
reality of the thing we say this all the
time left wingers like the appearance
they don't like the reality they like
decaf coffee they like
vegan bacon they like all of those
things they want the niceties the facade
they don't want the essence we have got
to make Democrats deal with the essence
of their terrible policies it's a
brilliant idea
we'll the left deal with consequences
we'll see one of those is the left has
been calling for Donald Trump's tax
returns now for years why I don't know
who cares what is in the tax returns so
this is now coming back to bite the
Democrats Bernie Sanders who's been
running for president non-stop since
2015 has only released a one-page or
two-page summary of one year of his
taxes so now finally he's got to release
his taxes and we found out why he didn't
want to do it before because it turns
out that Bernie Sanders who is
constantly saying that millionaires
aren't paying enough they're not giving
their fair share they're not helping
people out Bernie Sanders who's really
generous when it comes to your money
Bernie Sanders who knows how to spend
your money like no other
turns out he barely gives anything to
charity he has only once barely given
more than four percent of his income to
charity twice he's given a little more
than three percent twice he's given
about two and a half percent and five
times he's given less than two percent
of his income to charity he's so
generous when it comes to other people's
money he wants the appearance of being
this generous charitable person
everything will be free we're gonna give
everything away for free you doesn't
want the reality of of forking over his
own money no no no he's gonna fork over
your money now this is a good line we'll
be able to hit him with it I don't think
it's gonna really affect his standing in
the Democrat primaries and by the way he
is currently at the top of the heap I
still don't think he's gonna go all the
way but he is now running a different
campaign than he was running before
Bernie Sanders is now running to win
he's not running an ideological pure
campaign he's not running a campaign to
send a message to change the Democrat
Party Bernie Sanders is now running to
win how do we know that because he went
on Fox News he went out to reach a lot
of those voters who used to like Bernie
then they like Trump maybe now they like
Bernie again not the latte-sipping
liberal Los Angeles people
former Democrats who have now gone over
to Republicans that he wants to win back
he goes and he does this Town Hall and
President Trump was unhappy about this
the whole affair went relatively well
and it especially went well for one of
Bernie Sanders key policies Medicare for
all look at how they respond to Bernie's
proposal of Medicare for all I want to
ask the audience a question if you could
raise your hand here a show of hands of
how many people get their insurance from
work private insurance right now how
many get it from private charts okay now
of those how many are willing to
transition to what the senator says a
government-run system that's a lot of
people now this isn't exactly scientific
we don't know who's stacked that event
we don't know if it was all just Bernie
fans who came out to watch it the Bernie
fans are pretty intense and they do
often show up for him so I don't know it
could be that regardless Medicare for
all is another one of these examples
where when you say people to people hey
do you want Medicare for all it pulls
very well people really like the idea
when you explain to them that it costs
money
when you explain to them that they'll
have to pay they'll probably lose their
doctor they'll do all of these things
then all of a sudden people hate it then
all of a sudden people don't like it so
much now that is the interjection of
reality into that debate we cannot let
them get away with this just as
president Trump's idea to drop off
illegal aliens in sanctuary cities is
politically brilliant the term
medicare-for-all has proved politically
quite brilliant
I thought the downside was it seems so
decayed it seems so makes you feel like
I'm a strapping twenty year old and yet
I'm gonna get this program that's meant
for 70 year olds that doesn't I don't
want Medicare I want to be a young
strapping guy nevertheless it polls very
well because the Medicare program pulls
well it's also dishonest it is not
Medicare for all Medicare is
government-funded health care but it's
not government-run health care it's not
single-payer health care
medicare-for-all is socialist healthcare
medicare-for-all is a government-run
health care that you have to fund good
luck coming up with that money now
Bernie Sanders is going to have a lot of
success running this is why every
Democrat is running on Medicare for all
so we have to constantly do is say look
at the cost look at which doctor you're
gonna lose did you like Obamacare Obama
cares nothing compared to Medicare for
all look at this look at how it'll
affect this part of the economy look
it'll be a takeover of 1/6 of the US
economy it'll take away your ability to
control life-and-death decisions it will
look like some of these awful cases
we've seen in the UK where parents are
not allowed to save their baby
the hospital says we own your baby the
government says that baby's ours you you
don't have any say over it that's how
we're going to argue it this has to run
other issues too this is strong guns
Kamala Harris just came out she said I'm
a gun owner guns for me but not for thee
still defends gun confiscation policies
I am a gun owner and I own a gun for
probably the reason that a lot of people
do from personal safety I was a
prosecutor and in terms of gun policy
though I think that for too long and
still today we are being offered a false
choice which suggests you're either in
favor at the Second Amendment or you
want to take everyone's guns away it's a
false choice and it is I believe a cross
choice that is born out of the lack of
courage from leaders we must recognize
and agree that there are some practical
solutions to what is a clear problem in
our country and part of the practical
solution is to agree that we need smart
gun safety laws which include universal
background checks which include a
renewal of the assault weapons ban
period it's a false choice it's a false
choice look I'm gonna keep my gun and
then I'm gonna take away everyone else's
guns it's a false choice where
everyone's gonna get everything we're
gonna be everything to everybody don't
worry everything's gonna be great
no you don't get that you don't get the
appearance of defending our civil
liberties in the Second Amendment
meanwhile you're taking away our guns
listen to what she says I have a gun
yeah but we're gonna take away assault
weapons
what's an assault weapon talk about
appearance versus reality they classify
assault weapons based strictly on the
appearance of the gun and they create a
false impression that this gun is some
fully automatic machine gun when it's
not if you pull the trigger once and one
bullet comes out we have to get rid of
assault weapons assault weapons are one
of the most popular guns in America the
ar-15 is one of the most popular guns in
America for a reason it's a good gun
it's cheap effective no no guns for me
but not for thee we have to point to the
reality we'll say okay if Kamala
Harris's policies go into effect then
one of the most popular guns in America
is gone presumably it's going to be
confiscated from you she said we can't
have these ar-15s walking around on the
streets first of all I don't know if
you've ever known this I don't have you
ever seen a gun guns don't sprout legs
and start walking around on the street
they don't randomly
people either actually the way that guns
move around and shoot people is that
individuals buy them and have them and
scheme and plan and then shoot people
with them criminals do that the guns
don't do them themselves
so she says look we're gonna we're gonna
take away one of the most popular guns
in America but I support the Second
Amendment no no you don't and you know
what else we've got to point out even if
she took away all of those guns it would
not reduce gun homicides by any
statistically significant number very
very very few people each year are
killed by ar-15s or assault weapons or
rifles of any kind for that matter don't
let them get away with this false
appearance and then I could not finish a
discussion of 2020 without the biggest
news the race is totally being shaken up
President Trump has a Republican primary
challenger oh my gosh who's it gonna be
as a Ted Cruz is it Marco Rubio and no
it's bill weld bill weld who I guess was
governor of some state like 30 years ago
or something and he's kind of a Democrat
here is bill welds big campaign
announcement
Massachusetts 1990 a state near
bankruptcy corrupt Democratic machine
they called it taxa chooses one-party
rule no Republican governor for twenty
years
one man had the courage to stand up and
fight a crime fighter appointed US
Attorney by Ronald Reagan bill weld ran
for governor on his record top Boston
city officials retire they claim
accidents US Attorney bill weld
investigates the claims fraudulent weld
prosecutors gets broad conviction jail
millions saved in taxes now bill well
runs for governor his platform what it's
always been
guts integrity independence they said it
couldn't be done
no Republican could win he'll well beat
the odds historic victory bill weld cut
taxes 21 times he balanced the budget
reformed welfare
oh it's so cringy obviously I don't
think President Trump is shaking in his
Oval Office at the fear of bill weld
running in the GOP primary this campaign
announcement is terrible for a great
many reasons in its form and its
function it just reminds people that
bill weld is a has-been
it just reminds people that this guy
hasn't done anything in like 30 years
that he's from an older era that is he's
not connected to modern and relevant
politics not just in the way that
they're talking about his career he was
appointed by Ronald Reagan how old is he
he was governor in like 1990 or
something okay not just that even in the
form of the commercial it just feels
like a commercial from 2002 feels like a
commercial before the internet really
existed it just feels so dated because
he's a dated candidate but I bring it up
not just to make fun of Bill weld but to
point out that even his platform even
his ideological moorings are dated
they're dated and we're not gonna win
this way anymore what is what this
entire campaign announcement could be
boiled down to three words I cut taxes
hi I'm bill weld I cut taxes yeah my
entire political career basically I cut
taxes
isn't that great I cut tax yeah sure I
like low taxes as much as the next guy I
certainly enjoy low taxes don't get me
wrong
politics is a lot more than cutting
taxes conservative thought is a lot more
than cutting taxes imagine thinking that
you can stir men's souls by saying I cut
taxes not just 17 times but 21 times and
if you elect me I'll cut taxes a 20
second time I'm bill well I cut taxes
imagine is that going to stir men's
souls or are images of the burning
Cathedral of Notre Dom what what moves
you more are you moved by saving $400 on
your taxes in 2022 or are you moved by
more than economic matters Winston
Churchill said when great forces are on
the move in the world we know that we're
spirits not animals the destiny of man
is not measured by material computations
it's not just about the taxes it's not
just even about the politics it's about
the culture it's about our traditions
it's about what makes a nation a nation
what binds us to our neighbors what
binds us to our communities what binds
us to our history what binds us to our
God those questions will dominate moral
discourse will dominate the 2020
election we're not talking about
reforming welfare or some wonky program
or cutting taxes we're talking about
fundamental questions what is a nation
what is sovereignty who are illegal
aliens what is open borders who are my
countrymen what is my country what is my
country based on why do our national
monuments matter why does the cathedral
at Notre Dom matter because it has
expensive artwork inside it or because
it is a place in which we worship our
Creator the God who made us and who
loves us
what is our civilization the faith is
Europe Europe is the faith that was true
is that true is that true anymore what
is the West what is the United States
it's a lot more than cutting taxes all
right come on out to Texas A&M tonight
we're gonna have a great show with drew
we're have a great discussion hopefully
no one tries to throw chemicals on me or
anything like that this time
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Noel's show see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka watts and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 today on the
Ben Shapiro show Notre Dame burns Bernie
Sanders heads over to Fox News and Nancy
Pelosi struggles with the fresh faces
that's today on the bench Shapiro show